[Music]
go back 3,000 years to Ulysses who
fought in the Trojan War and was coming
home to his island of Ithaca on his
ships with his men and he realized that
he had this amazing opportunity which is
he was going to pass the island of the
siren and he knew that the sirens sang
so beautifully and we're so seductive
that mortal men would crash their ships
into the rocks and they'd all die every
time you heard the song of sirens you
were going to die he wanted to hear the
song of siren so what did he do the
Ulysses of present sound mind made a
contract with the future Ulysses he said
I know that guy is going to behave badly
when he hears the sirens song so what
did he do he lashed himself to the mast
exactly and he filled his men's ears
with beeswax and he said no matter what
I do keep on growing just ignore
everything keep on going in that way he
got to hear the siren song but he didn't
crash in the rocks because he was lashed
to the mast and so this is what is known
as the Ulysses contract which is your
present self making a contract with your
future self pending in constraining the
behavior of your future self so that it
has to do the right thing given your
long-term thinking that you're doing now
and so when it comes to something like
you know like the cookies Ulysses
contract it's more than I'm going to eat
it or not eat it it can be something
like okay look if I eat cookies I'm
going to promise my spouse that I'll go
to the gym tonight that's the kind of
way that we can can bring these sorts of
things into our own live and so I'll
give you um I'll give you several
examples over the phasors so what we've
seen so far is that there's this great
seduction in the now and so if we want
to do something where we actually are
navigating our future selves in a better
way we have to establish these kinds of
contracts with ourselves this is one of
the most important sort of life lessons
that I've got
something like New Year's resolution
everybody has really good New Year's
resolutions and believes they're going
to do it and by the end of January for
almost everybody these things have
fallen away why it's not because you
didn't mean it in January because you
didn't set up the structures in your
life Ulysses contract to make sure that
that went through it's not enough to
make a promise and a resolution with
good intention you need to understand
what's actually happening so that you
can do something about it so what I want
to do is suggest actionable steps by
which we can actually keep our
resolutions to ourselves a little bit
longer so the first one is is building
fences around yourself by minimizing
temptation so for example in alcoholics
Anonymous the very first thing you tell
you is you've got to clear all the
alcohol out of your house why it's
because on a festive Friday night or a
lonely Sunday night you're going to
you're going to go and drink it even if
you think no I'm done I'm not going to
drink that I'm going to keep those in
there with smokers the first thing
they're told in these rehab programs is
don't hang out with other smokers with
with drug addicts who are trying to quit
the first thing they're told in drug
rehab programs is make sure you never
carry more than 20 bucks of cash with
you because if you have the cash no
matter what your resolution is you know
you meet somebody in the alley who
offers you drugs you feel like oh yeah
I've got this money anyway and so you do
it so the issue is not tempting
temptation I was recently on a college
campus giving a talk and I met these
kids afterwards who during finals week
what they do is they swap Facebook
passwords with each other and they
change those passwords so they can't log
into Facebook when they're supposed to
be studying and as the end of finals
when it's all over they give each
other's passwords back it's very clever
and that's a beautiful sort of Ulysses
contract where we're a week before
finals your your knowing about the
temptations that you're going to give
into and you're doing something to pick
terrorism by now a lot has been said
about the marshmallow test you guys
probably know about this where you know
children are asked you can eat this one
marshmallow now or if you wait until I
come back you can get two marshmallows
people talk about this in terms of the
the resolution that little kids have and
how good they are resisting temptation
stuff but but there's something that's
often overlooked here which is that one
of the most common strategies that kids
use with simply covering their eyes just
clapping their hands with their eyes so
they're not looking at the marshmallow
and it turns out that's a very effective
strategy and so when we think about
minimizing temptation whatever your
temptations are in life just think about
the ways that you can actually
contractually minimize that temptation
so it's not they're not a fake not a
fake thing we think oh yeah I want to if
it's in the back of the cabin I will do
it but like actually get rid of
temptation
[Music]